تذكر
المرح ، تذكر المغامرة ، تذكر أن الضحك
فورد هو الذي يعيد
برونكو لإثبات
أنها مركبة قد يتذكرها البعض منكم
من هذا
ولكن ليس أن
هذه برونكو هي نسخة جديدة من الستينيات
الكلاسيكية لفورد برونكو الأصلي موستانج
للطرق الوعرة  الممرات
كما ترون ، تريد فورد أن تتسخها
، ومع الإطارات الضخمة والأبواب القابلة للإزالة
والتعليق
المرتفع ، فإن برونكو لا تتظاهر فقط بأنها
آلة لجميع التضاريس
حتى أن الجزء الداخلي مصمم
للقيادة على الطرق الوعرة بأزرار يسهل الوصول إليها ،
لذلك  يمكنك القيام بأشياء مثل قفل المحاور الأمامية ،
وقفل المحاور الخلفية ،
وقفلهما ومقبض كبير لإعداد
أوضاع قيادة مختلفة حتى تتمكن من
تغيير شخصية
السيارة وكيف تتصرف على
أنواع مختلفة من التضاريس
، واستثمارات فورد في ماركة برونكو  هائلة
ليس فقط لأنهم قاموا بإنشاء مجموعة من
موالف الطرق الوعرة والإصدارات الفاخرة
وحتى نموذج رياضي برونكو صديق الرصيف
ولكنهم قاموا أيضًا ببناء
أربعة إعلانات للطرق الوعرة  ملاعب المغامرة في
جميع أنحاء البلاد
لتستمتع بوقتك مع برونكو عندما تخرج إلى
هنا ، عليك أن تتذكر
فورد ، من الواضح أنه حدد هذه المسارات
لإظهار ما
يمكن أن يفعله برونكو في ظل الظروف القاسية ،
ويمكنك معرفة سبب
عدم رغبتهم في أن يأتي الناس.  هؤلاء في
سيارات هوندا crvs و ford escapes
لن يتمكنوا من الخروج من الطرف الآخر ،
لكن من الواضح أنه مع المساعدة العرضية
لأدلة المسار ،
حتى المبتدئ مثلي يمكنه أن ينفجر
في هذا الشيء
ولكننا بحاجة إلى التحدث عن رانجلر
في  الغرفة هنا لثانية واحدة فقط
، من الواضح تمامًا ما هي السيارة الرابعة التي
تتنافس ضد رانجلر الجيب التي كانت تمتلك
كل هذه المساحة لنفسها لفترة طويلة جدًا ،
لكن برونكو هو منافس جاد
، ربما يكون جيدًا على الطرق الوعرة
مثل رانجلر ولكن حتى أجمل  من
رانجلر على
الطريق وربما هو شيء اقتباس من جيب
ولكن يبدو أن فورد على مستوى التحدي ،
لا يوجد شيء أكثر متعة من بعض
المنافسة الجيدة وقد بدأت مسابقات رعاة البقر
للتو